changeons de registre et d'humeur et
parlons enfin d'amour l'amour c'est
entre autres on le sait une histoire de
longueur d'onde
jean jacques dufour et bruno carette
l'ont découvert à leur avantage ou à
leur dépens dans leur vagabondage
estivale c'est triste et solitaire
vous enviez les couples qui s'aiment
mais vous hésitez à vous jeter à l'eau
de peur d'être éconduits timide de tous
les pays réjouissez-vous le bip bip de
l'amour est arrivé c'est le plat chine
ce que vous entendez là ce n'est pas le
bruit d'une ambulance et le bruit qui
met le plat chine alors le flashing je
vous lis ce qui est écrit sur la notice
c'est la drague électronique ça permet
de faire perdre en compte simple et
compact et c'est une petite boîte de la
taille d'un paquet de cigarettes ça
sport sur soi n'importe quand n'importe
où et quand vous croisez un autre ou une
autre processeur de flashing ça émet un
bip sonore autrement dit le plat chine
ça permet de faire des tas de gros ainsi
plus de risques de se faire traiter de
sadik si vous abordez un autre
possesseur de plasil puisque c'est le
signe de l'ardent désir de faire des
rencontres
inventé par une self made woman qui a
peut être souffert ce merveilleux petit
appareil possède plusieurs fréquences et
fréquence santé des fréquences
hommes-femmes
ce sont des fréquences
homosexuel des fréquences lesbiennes et
des fréquences couples échangistes
nous avons en fait penser à tout le
monde parce qu'il ya de la place et du
coup pour tout le monde
voilà une intention digne d'une vraie
démocrate
mais vous même vous êtes timide non je
ne suis pas tellement timide mais je me
vois mal par exemple aller dans la rue
accrochez quelqu'un lui demander est ce
que vous pourriez parler avec moi un
petit peu quart d'heure elle un petit
quart d'heure vous prenez un café avec
moi non ça je ne vois pas
donc je pense que si je sors mon avec
mon flashy et si je vais dans la rue et
je rencontre quelqu'un ça c'est beaucoup
plus facile parce que je cède avance qui
voudraient rencontrer également
quelqu'un mac luhan plus fort que bute
imbert et ses petites annonces ça se
discute d'abord il y a peu de plats
chine sur le marché
aussi le risque est de faire de nombreux
kilomètres avant de rencontrer l'âme
soeur détentrice de la boîte noire
similaire
et puis ça coûte 950 francs enfin vous
pouvez vous tromper de fréquences en
manipulant l'appareil est alors
attention aux surprises
jouant souvent qu'on joue wyman
honnêtement non vraiment laissé stora
courage et qui m'est fait surtout
attention à l'état de vos piles sinon
vous risquez d'attendre longtemps le
signal sonore du coup de foudre
il paraît que ça marche même dans les
espaces verts etc